if I was in a coma and I smell this I'll
probably wake up saying I want whatever
this whatever this this is judging by
the name moonshiner is going to be a
nice chanting it's gonna be little stars
in your head I'm trusting you with us
think of it as like the American version
of Santa barely legal and it's very
potent I just hope I don't uh I don't
wake up below the ceiling I've been told
my capacity is good
so we shall feel it smell exciting that
smells like petrol unknown today looks
quite yummy exchanging my mouth it
doesn't taste anything like a cranberry
there was a mini explosion in my mouth
it's incredibly hard for me to believe
that this is going to get me high and
yet as I say this I feel it this here is
some apple pie moonshine it smell like
one
I'm at home full of look totally fine
and then you're gonna have it in cookie
jar it looks like diluted this year it's
like a warm feeling spreading through my
body we have this instead of my morning
coffee it just feels like it's honking
you're like wow this will and now it's
like if I go to a bar with this and an
open credit card that's it oh the end of
my life could emerge the next day like
on the streets of our man it says shine
responsibly at the back of the morning
shine responsibly you crazy diamond it's
gonna be horrible for all the exes I'm
going to text after this oh I'm sorry
that's like really cheap cheaper stuff
cheap what girls the moment I do curse a
virus it just hit to me like it smell
regret you remove that scene in Harry
Potter when Dumbledore how to drink that
portion and he was dying
watch me Frank can't daddy yeah daddy
which I guess is a great name if you are
into cats and daddy issues
smells sweet smells very sweet it's been
a very bad day this is making it amazing
right now
yes this is like a desert it was curry
with my that's some scary alcohol would
really like to have this food clothes
than mine maybe on Valentine's Day I can
do like multiple shots of this [ __ ] yeah
every day if I have to review this like
a master chef chef I think it's fruity
followed by spicy followed by alcohol
like it's very Indian yeah very very in
very Indian this is the Lord more
palatable compared to Indian to Sandra I
thought illicit liquor in the US would
be like you know bad but it was good it
doesn't feel like it's alcohol you know
I mean but I feel so good you know like
I just feel so good I feel at peace
I